سيد النهاد طبعا بالنظر الى الاخبار
العاجله المتعلق بالتحقيق الاولي للجيش
وهو يتحدث عن قتل ثلاثه من
المحتجزين اثناء رفعهم الرايات البيضاء و
الضابط الذي تحدث لوسائل الاعلام عن ان
هذا السيناريو وتجول الاسرى بحريه كما قال
وتقول روايه الجيش لم يكن
الجيش يتوقع ذلك و خرق قواعد الاشتباك
برايك خروج هذا التحقيق الاولي من الجيش
بهذه السرعه وهذه
التفاصيل ما انعكاساته ايضا على الداخل
الاسرائيلي مساء الخير وتحياتي لكم
ومشاهدين يعني في نهايه المطاف هناك جدل
هناك نقاش هناك بدايه يعني ولو طفيفه ولو
يعني بالتدريج لتفكك الاجتماع الاجماع
الاسرائيلي على الحرب يعني قبل اسابيع كنا
نشهد حاله من الاجماع الشامل من قبل كل
القوى الصهيونيه والتكتلات والاعلاميين
والجنرالات متقاعدين السلطه والمعارضه
كلهم متفقون على الحرب وعلى الانتقام من
الفلسطينيين هذا بدا يتراجع في ضوء عده
عوامل من بينها اهمال قضيه الاسرى وعدم
اعطاءها الاولويه المطلوبه لكن الان حركه
الاحتجاج بشان الاسرى تتسع يوما بعد يوم
بالاضافه الى ذلك الخ الفاتحه في صفوف
الجيش ايضا يعني هل يستحق من اجل ماذا
يعني يقتل هؤلاء الابناء كما يسمونهم هل
من من اجل تحقيق اغراض واهداف شخصيه لدى
نتنياهو او لدى اعضاء مجلس الحرب ام من
اجل اهداف استراتيجيه لاسرائيل من الواضح
تماما ان اسرائيل دمرت النسبه الكبرى من
قطع غزه ولم تمس بقدرات حماس هذا ما يعني
يتضح تماما كما انها اهملت موضوع الاسرى
فلذلك هذه التسريبات ليس من شانها الا ان
تؤجج هذا النقاش وت تخرجه من طور النقاش
العملياتي التفصيلي الثانوي الذي يرتبط
بتعليمات هذا الضابط وسلوك ذاك الجندي
المساله ليست عند الوحده التي كانت موجوده
في ذلك الموقع بل المساله عند الحكومه اي
هي ربما تكون محاوله لاعفاء الحكومه من
مسؤولياتها هنا يكمل الخلل عند الحكومه
التي ما زالت تعتقد انها اي ستسترجع
الاسرى من خلال مواصله الضغط على حماس لكن
70 يوما مثل هذا التكتيك وهذه السياسه
وهذا الضغط وهذا القتل لم تنجح هذه
الحكومه ولا جيشها في الافراج عن اسير
واحد لا بل ان ثلاث محاولات فاشله على
الاقل يعني عادت بنتائج ماساويه وبالتالي
القاء التهمه على جندي او على ضابط هذا
بمثابه اختيار كبش فداء يعني صغير المنزله
لكي يقولوا هو المسؤول وانه خالف تعليمات
اطلاق النار بالمناسبه حول تعليمات اطلاق
النار يعني عفوا يعني شخصيا اجريت بحثا
حول هذا الموضوع يت ت بين ان تعليمات
اطلاق النار هي وثيقه معقده من 14 صفحه
باي ف وهي تعليمات معقده ربما يحتاج
الجندي الى محامي الى جانبه في كل خطوه
حتى يعرف ما هي تعليمات اطلاق النار اذاء
الوضع المعقد جدا لكن غالبا ما يتبع
الجنود والضباط التعليمات الشفويه وهي لا
يمكن تسجيلها ولا توثيقها مثلك تعليمات
خاصه ب بهذا الظرف في غزه صح صح هناك مثلا
تعليمات هانيبال التي ت تعني القضاء على
الاسرى وعلى اسرم معا هذه التعليمات
حرمتها المحكمه العسكريه لكنها مرست بعد
ذلك اكثر من مره في معركه الشجاعيه عام
2014 وفي معركه رفح بنفس السنه وايضا في
هذه المعركه كما ثبت في مجارى بغلاف غزه
ولا استبعد ان شيئا من هذا القبيل جرى في
المواقع التي قتل فيها الاسرى اسرائيل
تفضل الاسرى ان يكونوا ميتين لا ان يكونوا
احياء وورقه بيد المقاومه لذلك انا اعتقد
ان المسؤوليه هي سياسيه وتعليمات اطلاق
النار هي نوع من الحجه او محاوله لحصر
المسؤوليه في جندي او في ضابط وليس
بالقرار السياسي الاسرائيلي الذي يريد ان
يندفع في هذه الحرب حتى اباده غزه واباده
شعبها والقضاء على كل يعني فرص الحياه
الطبيعيه فيها واما الحديث عن استعاده
الاسرى والقضاء على حماس سواى ط ذر للرماد
في العيون طيب هذه القطه يعني سياسيا وانت
متابع سياسيا كيف تغيرت المواقف
حتى المهل التي اشير اليها امريكيا للجيش
الاسرائيلي بالانتقال الى مرحله اخرى وبعض
يعني التسريبات كانت تتحدث عن عن افق
لنهايه هذه
الحرب واهداف الحرب المعلنه القضاء على
المقاومه واضيف اليها طبعا استعا عاده
المحتجزين الان كيف ستكون نهايه هذه
المعركه باي اهداف و و وباي صوره نصر
بالنسبه لاسرائيل
انا اعتقد ان ثمه تباينات بين الموقفين
الرسميين الاسرائيلي والامريكي لكنها لا
ترقى الى مستوى الخلاف الجدي حول اهداف
الحرب يعني نحن سمعنا تحفظات وملاحظات من
قبل الرئيس بايدن ومن بعده من عدد من
المسؤولين التي تتحفظ على ما اسمي القصف
العشوائي وعلى فكره هذا مش قص ليس قصفا
عشوائيا هذا قصف مقصود لانه هدف الاباده
وليس هدفه [__] استهداف يعني قياده حماس او
عناصر حماس ثانيا هناك خلاف على اعاده
احتلال او اقتطاع جزء من مساحه قطاع غزه
وهناك خلاف حول عوده السلطه الفلسطينيه
هذه الخلافات نفسها هي خلافات بين القوى
الاسرائيليه نفسها ولكنها لا ترقى ولا تصل
الى مستوى الخلاف على الاهداف البعيده
للحرب وهي هي القضاء على حماس ويعني كي
الوعي الفلسطيني بمعنى خلق انطباع عميق في
الوعي الوطني الشعبي الفلسطيني با استحاله
مواجهه اسرائيل وتشكيل مثال للردع يعني
يمنع اي طرف عربي او اقليمي من التفكير
ايضا بالتصدي لاسرائيل لذلك انا اعتقد انه
بعد زياره جيك سوليفان جرى التوصل الى
صيغه وسط وهي الصيغه اصلا معتمده كانت من
قبل الجيش الاسرائيلي الذي قسم هذا الحرب
الى اربعه مراحل اولا القصف الشامل ثانيا
الدخول البري ثالثا ما يسمى مرحله التمشيط
او التطهير حسب التعبير العبري وهي هذه
المرحله التي بدا الجيش بالدخول لها حيث
من الصعب على الجيش ان يفرض يعني شروطا
سياسيه وان يفرض حلولا نهائيه الا اذا خرج
جنوده من المدرعات وبداوا يفتشون في
الابنيه وفي المواقع المختلفه المرحله
الرابعه وهي جزء لا يتجزا من الحرب هي
التسويه السياسيه هذه التسويه السياسيه
ليست سؤالا في نظريا حول سيناريوهات ما
بعد الحرب بل هي جزء لا يتجزا من الحرب
حيث ان اسرائيل تريد تنصيب قياده مدنيه
فلسطينيه خاضعه لها واعتقد ان هذه المسائل
يعني صحيح انها تمثل يعني خلافات وتباينات
طفيفه بين الولايات المتحده واسرائيل لكن
الولايات المتحده في نهايه المطاف يعني لا
تضغط على اسرائيل هي ت تقدم وجهات نظرها
كنصح وكار الشادات وتكرر انها لا تم تؤيد
الموقف الفلاني ولا تدعم احتلال قطاع غزه
اي ليست صارمه ولا حاسمه في منع اسرائيل
من تحويل هذه الحرب الى حرب يعني توسعيه
استيطاني وتهجير تؤدي الى تهجير سكان قطاع
غزه وعوده الاستيطان لذلك انا اعتقد ان
ثمه يعني فرصه لتسويه هذه الخلافات خصوصا
انه في نفس الوقت الذي نسمع به عن هذه
الخلافات نرى الولايات المتحده تصوت ضد
قرارات وقف اطلاق النار في الجمعيه العامه
وفي وقبلها في مجلس الامن لا بل ان بعض
المسؤولين الام امريكيين يعني يتنطع
للتعبير عن اهداف الحرب الامريكيه من قبيل
مثلا ان هذه الحرب لن تتوقف الا اذا
استسلمت حماس هذا لم نسمعه من المسؤولين
الاسرائيليين اهداف الح اهداف الحرب
الاسرائيليه تتطوع ل تتحدث عن اهداف
اسرائيل من الحرب على العموم دقل هذا
الكلام الامريكيين نعم دعني انتقل معك الى
نقطه اخرى وقضيه اجتماع جلنت اليوم واليوم
سبت في اسرائيل يجتمع
ب رئيس الاركان مساد الشباك جهاز الامن
العام طبعا وغيرهم على خلفيه الحدث الذي
جرى في الشجاعيه تقول هيئه البث ايه ان
هذا الاجتماع
يناقش جهود اعاده المختطفين ما الذي تقراه
في اجتماع
السبت انا اعتقد انه اجتماع يعني شوف هناك
حديث انه يوم السبت يوم مقدس ومحرم فيه
الاجتماعات لكن في اوضاع الطوارئ ويعني
هذه يفتي بها
رجال الدين انه اذا الامر تطلب انقاذ حياه
يمكن لهم ان ان يتجاوزوا الحرومات ولذلك
هناك حاله من الذعر ربما الارتباك الشديد
تبادل المسؤوليات اخفاق تلو الاخفاق وفشل
تلو الفشل ولذلك يجتمعون في يوم السبت وفي
غير يوم السبت لتدارك الامر هل سيدفع بهم
ذلك الى تبني المطالب التي يطرحها الاسر
تطرحها المقاومه ويطرحها المحتجون اللي هي
صيغه الكل مقابل الكل انا اعتقد انهم ربما
في النهايه يضغط عليهم يوميا من خلال
خسائر العسكر والجيش من خلال الفشل تلوى
الفشل في تحقيق انجازات ومن خلال ايضا
الكوارث التي تؤدي اليها محاولات الافراج
عن الاسرى بالقوه بالاضافه الى اتساع
حركات الاحتجاج والملاحظات النقديه
الامريكيه كل هذه العوامل اذا اضفنا اليها
ايضا العزله الدوليه وما قاله لويد اوستن
وهو كلام مهم جدا ان خسائر اسرائيل
الاستراتيجيه قد تفوق مك سبها التكتيكيه
بمعنى ان اسرائيل فعلا تقتل وتبيد و يعني
تصنع يعني كثير من الانجازات اليوميه
لكنها على المدى الطويل قد تخسر مكانتها
وسمعتها وفرصها في التطبيع وفرصها في
الاندماج بالاقليم كما انها باتت دوله
معزوله ومنبوذ كما دلل على ذلك اماع
الجمعيه العامه للامم شكرا شكرا جزيلا لك
سيد هاد ابو غوش من رام الله الخبير في
الشان الاسرائيلي شكرا لك